[Musique]
en tout cas à l'échelle de la France ça
représente vraiment un symbole et une
tradition française d'aller à la
boulangerie le matin de prendre du pain
pour manger au petit déj le midi le soir
à toutes les occasions et on résiste pas
à une bonne baguette bien chaude
c'est effectivement de l'eau du sel de
la levure de la farine et nous rajoute
du levain naturel mais on a beau avoir
tous les mêmes ingrédients tous à peu
près la même recette vous allez dans un
fournil ou dans un autre le pain il aura
pas le même goût c'est pas
effectivement une sorte de consécration
je veux dire le savoir-faire français
et puis la baguette tradition
ça
représente vraiment la culture française
mange du pain mange de la baguette c'est
de la transmission de l'humain à
l'humain et puis de l'ordre dans nos
mains quoi je veux dire c'est on peut
pas on peut pas
tu peux pas le transmettre sur un
bouquin Jonathan justement une
reconnaissance internationale qui va
permettre à des boulangers de
s'installer à l'étranger pour pour
représenter ce savoir-faire français et
également pour les touristes qui
viennent voir ici ils auront la chance
de goûter justement ce savoir-faire
reconnu au patrimoine mondial